so guess what we just got the DJI Mavic
it's DJI has new drone this thing is so
small so compact and so amazing we can
basically take it anywhere so today
we're gonna go do some really fun stuff
are you ready I am the first thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna go kayaking
because sure why not and the best part
about kayaking is they have tandem
kayaks so I can pilot the drone and
Jenica paddle tight a minute yeah let's
go
[Music]
oh man the best part about being a drone
pilot and kayaking is the fact that I
didn't really paddle at all
my arms are jello what else should we do
today I know you're under the beach
I'd like to the beach you're like
[Music]
I'm gonna try to fly the drone while I'm
playing basketball basketball you ain't
got UPS girl what guess we're gonna find
out
[Music]
see me from
never son
[Music]
time to try out the mattock here at the
trampoline park all is gonna be grew
you
all right so I'm gonna take the Mavic
I'm gonna follow Jenna over here to the
foam pit and we're gonna do some crazy
stuff probably not that crazy because
we're not really that feel at
trampolining but it's okay it comes from
the heart
the best part is I'm letting using the
controller I'm using my iphone to
control
[Music]
we are at the marina where you get some
cool shots of all of these sailboats
it's such a beautiful day it's pretty
much perfect drone flying weather
there's no wind the temperature is
perfect and the scenery is also perfect
[Music]
well guys that's the DJI Mavic hope you
guys love it as much as I do because
pretty much this thing is gonna change
my life I hope it changes your its to
buy so here is our Mavic and phantom for
comparison I mean this is I mean this is
great
here's our battery comparison oh here's
our controller size